[Musique]
les officiers de la police judiciaire on
tourne un des afghans rapatrié en france
il ya quelques jours et placé en garde à
vue hier soir l'homme de 30 ans fait
l'objet d'une surveillance
administrative et avaient interdiction
de quitter cet hôtel de noisy le grand
il mesure qu'il n'a pas respectée lui
qui a reconnu avoir tenu un barrage dans
kaboul comment at il pu faire partie des
quelques mille autres afghans évacués
par la france le gouvernement a une
explication parmi ces mille afghans y en
a eu effectivement un qui était
manifestement jeudi manifestement en
lien avec les talibans mais qui a
beaucoup aidé l'armée française les
français vos collègues journalistes si
j'ai bien compris il est donc plus
facile pour un taliban d'entrées en
france que pour un français d'entrer
dans un restaurant sans pass sanitaire
pardonner ce raccourci gelade mais
caricaturale de rapprocher un peu frais
n'ont rien à voir sans doute mais j'ai
l'intuition que tout le monde s'est fait
un peu la même réflexion
s'ils ont tous des torches c'est pas
brûler un sapin sans prendre ça symbole
de la bêtise humaine et de la
gourmandise et du coup j'ai ça je vais
pas passer sur le bûcher mois
l'extrême droite cherche un rubato et
arrêter de dire ce qu était d'abord de
dire que charles tourné la séquence
remplacer un journal intime et oui oui
oui alors oui très bien aux donc permis
à dire quoi qu'est ce que pourrait être
le rendez-vous alors jusqu'à deux
épisodes d'extrême droite son combat
face aux nazis quoi si vous voulez mais
à part ça oh ouais je la lui mais elle
est belle la mentalité de la télévision
est ce que vous vous seriez disponibles
pour venir voyager un peu avec nous
pendant deux trois jours vers la
sardaigne
une mamie la barre à me
contacter
dans cette étape de la côte d'azur tous
les résidents et les soignants ont été
complètement vaccinés contre le coc vie
désormais on se tient prêt à procéder à
l'injection d'une troisième dose pour
les volontaires qui ne devrait pas
manquer oui ça me dérangerait pas
j'avais déjà fédéré certain nombre d'ong
n'est plus un vaccin prêt pour que ça
fonctionne c'était normalement faites
vous vacciner maintenant vous dis
troisième dose qui me dit que dans simon
dira pas mais finalement
après je vais pas faire si dense et
windows et toute ma vie des doses que
les six mois je suis ravi d'être là vous
pouvez ma vie déclare sait comment ça se
passe sinon on est le parrain de
quelqu'un ça signifie circoncision
celle qui était alors temps à vous sans
danger pour ma classe il manque encore
avec nous on va passer aux débris de
sauter des matins qu'ils soient de
famille ou de la castafiore ils ont
toujours de la valeur
et ça n'est que le deuxième jour
[Applaudissements]
du coup de nombreux internautes sont
tombés sous le charme de cet homme de 29
ans condamné à trois ans de prison pour
trafic de drogue outre-manche tout est
parti de cette photo publiée par la
police anglaise
comment je peux rendre visite à stephen
s'il vous plaît c'est pour une amie il
est trop beau pour aller en prison
l'avis de stephen changera peut-être
comme celle de jeremy mix surnommé le
détenu le plus sexy du monde en 2014 ce
californien a commencé une carrière de
mannequin à sa sortie de prison il ya un
de tes neveux qui volent quelqu'un par
exemple tu penses que c'est une bonne
chose ou pas c'est parce qu'il a deux
gros tu dis s'il ya quelqu'un de ta
famille qui va voler dans une autre
famille c'est normal il en a besoin
qu'est ce qui se passe s'il ya quelqu'un
d'une autre famille qui vient voler dans
ta famille le cul mais c'est normal on a
besoin
[Rires]
aujourd'hui il ya un mouvement chinois
qui est basée sur leur peau qui connaît
un succès mondial il s'appelle temps
ping qui veut dire rester allongée et
l'incitent ses membres à en faire le
moins possible le but est d'être pas
trop stressé un petit peu comme philippe
noiret dans alexandre le bienheureux est
spécial ou pas oui alors vous savez
comment on fait connaissez le principe
chez nous quand on est stressé on crie
alors là je pense qu'on va avoir un
esprit de compétition préparez vous un
deux trois ah bah voilà c'est un jeune
chinois qui a lancé le mouvement au mois
d'avril en écrivant ces quelques mots
sur son blog je ne me marierai pas je
n'achèterai pas de maison je n'aurais
pas d'enfant je serai oisifs et bien ce
message a eu tellement de succès que
dans un sondage réalisé sur la
plateforme web os plus de 60 % des
chinois interrogés se disaient prêts à
adhérer à ce mouvement anti système
travailler moins pour profiter plus que
la vie en ville c'est pas une bonne
chose j'ai compris j'ai trop ordinateur
trop de télé chaque jour font payer pour
travailler c'est pas ça la vie
tu pas une vraie expérience
regarder le top 10 des acteurs et des
actrices hollywoodien les mieux payés le
top 10 vient d'être dévoilée 100
millions de dollars pour daniel craig et
dwayne johnson 50 millions de dollars 40
millions de dollars pour will smith donc
en 2021 jennifer lawrence et du lait
roberts à égalité 25 millions de dollars
et 20 millions de dollars pour sandra
blog des nouvelles du tournage de
mission impossible cette avec sept
cascades réalisées dans la campagne
anglaise une locomotive à vapeur lancé
sur des rails et dans le vide
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs internautes partagent des
vidéos de ce tournage spectaculaire
le septième film de la saga avec tom
cruise doit sortir au printemps prochain
c'est un regret va garder
le but lui
même est sérieuse
mais non mais non
merci je m'améliore
et mon corps
[Applaudissements]
alors
j'ai toujours voulu être avec sa guitare
au camping au feu mais tu la mettais
déjà
le bassiste dépasse d'investisseurs il
est comme le président de république
française
c'est avec une immense tristesse que
nous annonçons la mort de notre
bien-aimé charlie watts il s'en est allé
en paix dans un hôpital de londres cet
après-midi entouré de sa famille charlie
était un mari et mais en perd un grand
père mais aussi en tant que membre des
rolling stones l'un des meilleurs
batteurs de sa génération
les influences se sont tous les
musiciens de jazz je n'ai pas du tout
d'un lancement cannois laurent peut-être
chaque verrine
quand j'étais jeune je n'ai jamais
écouté elvis j'ai jamais